Il y a 3 ans, l'un des meilleurs jeu d'horreur de tout les temps arrivait entre nos mains.
*Cris d'horreur*
*Musique stressante*
Outlast 1
Et bien aujourd'hui on est sur la démo d'Outlast 2, allez c'est parti !
Hein ?
Play Demo, putain je suis tout excité comme une puce !
Bienvenue dans la démo d'Outlast 2
Vous êtes Blake Langermann, un caméraman qui travaille pour sa femme, Lynn
Vous êtes tout les deux journalistes et vous faites des investigations sur des histoires que personne n'ose approcher
Vous suivez une piste d'indices vous menant à l'assassinat impossible d'une femme enceinte qui s'appelle Jane Doe
L'enquête vous a mené bien profond dans le désert d'Arizona, dans une obscurité si profonde que personne n'y voit de lumière...
...une corruption tellement présente que la seule chose à faire est de devenir fou.
D'accord !
Parfait !
Bah ça nous met en confiance !
Ok c'est parti
Ohhhh, putain, j'attends ça depuis tellement d'années
Je suis très content
OK !
Wooooooww
Il a toujours des lunette le mec qui tombe, tout le temps
Ok, il a reprit ses lunettes
Parfait !
Woaaaaaa
Je suis blessé ? Non ça va ? Je peux bouger ?
Il n'y a rien, juste un peu mal à la tête
Ah ?! J'ai ma caméra !?
Ca.....c'est quand même la base
Putaiiiiiiin, mec
Mon gars, mais t'as envie de te buter, quoi, quand t'arrives là, haha !
Horrible, on dirait la maison de vacances, où tous les mecs en vacances se font assasiner
Appuyez sur "X" pour sauter...OK, bien évidement.
Appuyez sur "Q" pour prendre la pelle et tuer le méchant
Et finir Outlast 2
Oh non, non,faut pas...
Faut pas faire ça, mec
Putain ils ont condamné les fenêtres, et tout, nan mais faut vraiment pas aller là dedans
Allez on continue !
On n'est jamais trop prudent....on est bon
Il y a eu du bruit
Nan, ça devait être mes pas
Oh putaiiiiin
Oh putain m'en bas les couilles
Ah mais non mais il y a une histoire de batterie...avec des piles
Rahhh les enculés
Oh putain, mec, mais c'est quoi cet endroit ?
OOOOOOOOhhhhhhhhhh
Woooooooohhhh !!!
Oh ! C'est mon ombre
C'est mon ombre
*Une femme crie*
Oh putain ça crie de partout, en fait c'est des...Ils ont
Appuie "X" pour se cacher
Mais non ! Je peux me cacher dans le bidon
Pffff, la cachette bidon quoi
C'est gratuit
Ah d'accord ok, bah il est plus là maintenant ça sert plus à rien mais je saurai qu'on pourra se cacher dans les bidons
OK OK OK OK
Est-ce qu'on peut se cacher dans le seau éventuellement ?
Non...que les bidons, que les bidons.
Vous savez quoi ? Je vais toquer.
ah ah!
Ah "open windows" (ouvrir la fenêtre en anglais)
Le gars, il veut mourir ! Il a vu un mec... OH! *peur*
Putain...
Ok
Oh...pourquoi cette porte claque?
il arrive...? Y'a des bruits y'a des bruits y'a des bruits y'a des bruits !
Faut que j'me barre, faut que j'me barre !
Y'a des bruits...
Y'a un mec... Y'a un mec.
Ah non ! C'est juste cette putain de porte qui claque!
J'ai eu tellement peur !
Ok, on y va.
Oh putain ! C'est un cimetière, c'est tous les gens qui sont morts avant moi, c'est ça ?
Je ne gâcherai pas de batterie, on gardera la batterie pour les situation de crise.
Il faut qu'on soit bien organisé.
Ok j’avoue, je craque...
Putain, mais mec on voit carrément rien ! On voit rien !
Je vois rien !
Non mais là, là...
C'est du sang... Oh, c'est du sang...
Avec des peluches, mais non, ils n'ont pas tué des enfants quand même?
Oooh, j'imagine...
J'ose même pas imaginer ce qu'il y a là dedans mec pour qu'il y est autant de mouches...
ça doit sentir le cadavre...
Qu'est-ce qu'on a ici?
Ok
Oooh... *étonnement*
Ah, bah voilà...
Bah voilà mec...
MAIS C'EST DES ENFANTS!
Ok, faut continuer c'est par là.
On remonte...
On arrive sur un cheval...
...qui bouge tout seul, c'est parfait!
Y'A QUELQU'UN DANS LE PUITS?
Ouais... On va me pousser dedans.
On va me pousser dedans.
C'est sûr...
Mais lâche-moi calamar !
Wooaa ?!
Ok, on a atterit dans le puits.
Caméra ?
Caméra, vite !
C'est des conduits...
Maintenez "L1" pour regarder derrière.
Pourquoi il faudrait que je regarde derrière moi...?
Oh, non s'il vous plaît...
Non, non non...
Y'aura pas besoin, y'aura pas besoin y'aura pas besoin...
*bruits*
*coup dans le casier*
*cris de femme*
Tais-toi femme !
Tu vas énerver le monstre après il va me tuer aussi !
Quitte à être morte, autant ne pas attirer les autres dans ton malheur !
*petit rire*
J'suis caché !
C'est tombé, il n'y a rien dedans ! Pas la peine de regarder hein!
Putain, dans quoi j'ai atterri mec...
Dans quoi j'ai encore atterri quoi ? Mais c'est...
Oh, bah ça va ! C'est plutôt rassurant !
Sans déconner, je crois que c'est la seul fois où j'ai rêvé qu'un prof dise :
"Sortez vos livre page 32."
Vraiment !
Roooh... non mais mec.
Comment ? Même la lumière de cette pièce devrait éclairer un petit peu le couloir.
Abusez pas les gars quoi!
C'est fermé ça, bien sûr!
Et là derrière c'est fermé.
C'est fermé.
Bon, bah on va aller dans le noir...*bruit casier qui grince*
Oooh noon, nooooon...
S'il vous plaît, y'a rien là.
Là, y'a de la lumière, y'a de la lumière.
*rire d'homme sardonique*
Attends, mais le gars on dirait carrément qui rigole collé à mon oreille !
Putain mais mec... mais tout est fermé
Tout est 100% fermé, qu'est-ce que tu veux que je fasse !
Pourrai me cacher? Ok, je pourrai me cacher dans un casier
C'est sûr, ça va...
*voix d'homme*
J'ai cru voir...Ooh! j'ai cru voir un truc...
Mais pourquoi...?
...Mec, c'est n'importe quoi !
Arrêtez, arrêtez.
Aaaah!
Mais y'a bien une ombre!
ARRÊTEZ!
LES CASIERS LÀ!
AAAAAAAAAAH!
J'ai plus de batterie. Je vais mourir, je vais mourir...
Faut que je reparte là dedans sinon je vais mourir.
Mais...C'est fermé !
Mais je suis foutu ! J'ai plus de batterie, non !
Noon! mais tout est fermé !
Oh !
Y'a une putain ombre, mec ! Qui tourne, je l'ai vu !
La caméra elle va s'éteindre, on va mourir !
*cris du personnage*
*cris très viril de squeezie*
Aaah !
Ok, bon au final y'a une porte qui s'est ouverte.
J'ai eu trop de chatte et j'ai pu aller dedans...
...Voilà
Mon gars dans la vrai vie...
Imagine, imagine j'entends des bruits bizarre chez moi.
Et ma copine veut que j'aie voir ce qu'il se passe.
Je...mais c'est mort !
Je la prends comme ça, je la mets en boule et je l'envoie dans la pièce en question !
Et c'est elle qui va investir, investi, inves... euh... enquêter
J'arrive plus à parler...
*cris de jeune femme*
Putain, mais c'est sérieux...
Arrête !
Reviens là, Jessica !
Reviens là !
Pfff...
Bon, bah reviens pas.
Whaaaaat...?
Non mais attends, c'est quoi ce monstre, mec ?
C'est trop bizarre !
Tu penses qu'il faut que je passe en dessous en courant ou pas?
Il est là le truc, il va me niquer...
Regardez ! Il y a des sortes de mains !
Y'a des mains qui sorte de là !
Non, je vais me faire attraper mec.
bah, faut y aller. Je suis sûr qu'il faut y aller.
Faut aller à la porte qui est là !
Ah ! Les bâtards !
Oooh ! What the...
Lâche-moi, lâche-moi, lâche-moi !!
Et d'un coup je suis dans une maison ?
C'est trop bizarre !
Ok, je m'en bats les couilles, je cours je cours je cours je cours !
JE COURS JE COURS JE COURS JE COURS !!
PARDON MONSIEUR !
Oh putain !
OH PUTAIN !
Attends, on va ramper...
Putain de merde, y'a un gars.
Oh ! Il est juste là !
Juste là...
Ça va, ça va, ça va. Allez.
Allez Lucas, allez ! Putain!
Oh, des piles.
C'est pas là où il faut aller.
Aah!
M'en bats les couilles de la pile, je me barre!
Oh putain c'est par là, regarde.
Y'a des trucs pour sauter au dessus.
Non, non non non non...
J'y vais en courant ?
Je pense qu'il faut y aller en courant.
Mec, faut y aller en courant.
J'y vais en courant !
YES !
AAAAH !
Il m'aura pas, il m'aura pas, il ne m'aura pas !
Aaaah!
Ah! *??* j'ai esquivé ! J'ai esquivé !
Où j'vais, où j'vais ?!
OÙ J'VAIS ? ET C'EST QUOI ÇA ?!
AAAH !
VOUS M'AUREZ JAMAIS !
VOUS ALLEZ MOURIR.
DANS D'AFFREUSES SOUFFRANCES.
Je suis très mal placé pour dire ça.
C'est parti, c'est la sortie ça !
Allez, allez, allez !
Pourquoi ça fait ça ? C'est que je suis essoufflé ? Ouais !
Non ! non ! non ! Mais non y'a d'autre mec! Non, non, non ! Leave me alone !
C'est bon, je m'en suis sortie !
Oh putain ! Et ces putain de lunettes quoi ?!
Il veut pas les gluer?
OK !
OOK !
Je pose ça ici.
Voilà!
Il faut que je change ce qu'il y a sous ce pantalon...
PU...TAIN !
Qu'est-ce que ça donne envie de jouer au 2 à 1000% !
On fera un "let's play" sur le 2, c'est sûr et certain !
N’hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si vous vous êtes chié dessus autant que moi.
Ce screamer mec, vraiment, il m'a mis très très très très mal.
J'ai jamais eu peur au point de faire un cri aussi aigüe...C'est ouf !
Bordel, vivement, vivement...
Et merci d'avoir regardé
Vraiment très bonne démo, merci Red Barrels !
Vous nous vendez du rêve.
Aller, à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
Il va bien nous falloir 24 heures pour que l’adrénaline redescend un peu...
Portez-vous bien, à tchao tout le monde ! PEACE !